الام الامه
ان شاء الله بسم الله
يعني شعور لا يوصف والحمد لله ان العمليه
تكللت بالنجاح
والحمد لله سبحانه وتعالى ومن ثم الفريق
الطبي الذي يرعشه الدكتور عبد الله ربيعه
السياره ولكن ايضا سوف ناخذ هذه التفاصيل
بشكل بشكل
[موسيقى]
اليوم الدكتور نزار يعني تمت المرحله
الاولى وكنت تشرف عليها وهي مرحله التخدير
وهي من المراحل المهمه ايضا والان تواكب
المرحله الرابعه ادانا نتحدث عن هالمرحله
[موسيقى]
منذ دقائق تم خصل عمر عن علي والان فما
نشاهد عمر في طاوله ومستقله لاول مره في
حياته وعلي في طاوله مستقله الان تبدا
عمليه ترميم الاعضاء
وتاخذ لها وقت وان شاء الله تنتهي بنجاح
لكن المرحله الحرجه والصعبه ان شاء الله
اننا سيطرنا عليها
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه العراق هذه هذا هو التوام الخامس
سبق وانفصل مجموعه توائم فاطمه الزهراء
كذلك زينب ورقيه كذلك اياد
وزياد وكذلك كريس و كريستيانو علي وعمر
[موسيقى]